ONE EXPERT SAYING THERE IS NO
PAPER TRAIL.
>> INCREDIBLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> AFTER THAT FANTASTIC REPORT
GIVING ALL OF THOSE DETAILS, I
WANT TO GO TO COUNTESS ALEXANDER
TOLSTOY.
THEY SHARE THREE CHILDREN
TOGETHER.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND YOUR BEING WILLING TO SPEAK
TO ME.
I KNOW THESE ARE REALLY TRYING
TIMES.
YOU JUST HEARD DREW AND HE SAID
THERE'S LITERALLY NO PAPER
TRAIL.
I KNOW YOU LIVED IN THIS WORLD
FOR EIGHT YEARS AFTER YOU MET
SERGEI.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
>> WELL, IT WAS SORT OF LIKE
EVERYONE IMAGINED, LIKE THE GOD
FATHER.
THIS CRAZY, INSANE WORLD AND
COMPLETE LACK OF NORMAL HUMAN
MORALS, NO EMPATHY.
THERE'S A HUGE -- LIKE ANY
DICTATOR.
WE ALL HATE EACH OTHER, VERY
COMPETITIVE, THEY DON'T TRUST
EACH OTHER.
IT'S RUTHLESS.
>> SO YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
SERGEI IS THE FOCUS OF A BBC
DOCUMENTARY.
IT'S CALLED THE COUNTESS AND THE
RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE.
IT LAYS OUT HOW CLOSE SERGEI WAS
TO PUTIN AS PUTIN ROSE IN POWER.
HERE'S A CLIP FROM THE NETFLIX
DOCUMENTARY.
>> IT WAS A METEORIC ASCENT AND
SERGEI WAS SOMEONE WHO HELPED
PUSH PUTIN UP THE STAIRS.
>> Translator: YOU WERE MY
FRIEND.
WENT EVERYWHERE FOR A LONG TIME
AND WE WERE VERY, VERY CLOSE.
ALL THE TIME.
PUTIN WAS REALLY RELAXED AND WAS
READY TO DO WHATEVER WE WANT.
>> SERGEI CEMENTED HIS POWER BY
BECOMING IN THE UPPER
PARLIAMENT.
HE BECAME ONE OF PUTIN'S TRUSTED
ADVISERS.
>> SO YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT BEING
IN THE ROOM WITH PUTIN.
YOU'VE BEEN THERE.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
AND WHAT WAS PUTIN LIKE IN THOSE
TIMES?
>> SO I WAS IN THE ROOM WITH HIM
IN 2008 AND HE THEN WAS A VERY
DIFFERENT PERSON FROM WHAT I SEE
NOW IN THE NEWS.
HE WAS A VERY CONFIDENT PERSON.
HE HAD HIS GREAT, ENORMOUS
BALANCE OF BODY GUARDS.
HE WAS -- YOU COULD SEE HE WAS
SECURE, BUT HE WAS VERY
CONFIDENT.
NOW HE'S ANGRY AND OUT OF
CONTROL.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE.
>> THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT WHETHER HE'S CHANGED.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THIS ON THE
OUTSIDE, PEOPLE ARE SAYING IS IT
COVID ISOLATION, SOME SORT OF
ILLNESS?
LIKE I SAID, YOU KNOW HIM.
SERGEI USED TO TALK ABOUT PUTIN.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN TERMS OF
CHANGES, WHETHER PHYSICAL OR
OTHERWISE NOW?
>>.
>> I WOULD SAY THERE'S NOT SUCH
A HUGE CHANGE.
I THINK HE HAS A PERSONALITY
DISORDER.
NARCISSISTIC PERSONALITY
IT'S ALL ABOUT CONTROL.
HE FEELS MORE AND MORE -- YOU
CONSTANTLY HEAR THE WEST HAVE
HUMILIATED US, THE WEST HAVE
DISRESPECTED US, HE TA